alors est-ce que la mort de mon frère a
servi à quelque chose bon comme vous le
savez si ça avait servi à quelque chose
peut-être que Monsieur Dominique Bernard
sera sera encore là donc je pense
qu'effectivement
euh les mesures n'ont pas du tout été
prises puisque l'affaire de mon frère
n'a absolument pas été analysée parce
qu'il faut quand même comprendre que ce
qui arriva à mon frère on peut
effectivement pointer des
responsabilités à droite à gauche mais
c'est surtout comprendre l'entrrisme
islamique qui est à l'actuelle dans nos
écoles et qui prend de plus en plus de
place et
que si c'est pas entre guillemets une
menace de décapitation ça on va passer à
la menace d'une bombe la société est
devenu un chaos en fait à l'heure
actuelle donc autrement
donc donc par rapport donc aux
revendications donc des élèves ou des
parents d'élèves qui peuvent être
menaçants donc
donc effectivement ce qu'il faut surtout
donc ça retourne sur l'islamisme il faut
faut mener un combat
idéologique parce que en fin de compte
les mesures correctives on va protéger
un professeur évincer un élève le mettre
dans un établissement on va faire
convoquer le père de famille qui a pu
menacer et qui sera jugé souvent sous
des peines qui sont tout à fait
négligeables donc en fin de compte ça
entraîne récidive parce qu'en fait on
déplace les problèmes c'est un petit peu
comme si on appuyait sur un cancer et
qu'on disème des cellules cancéreuses un
petit peu partout donc euh voilà par par
rapport à ça pour moi c'est c'est
vraiment un combat que tout le monde
doit mener contre l'islamisme à l'heure
actuelle qui effectivement est en pleine
offensive et qui va de plus en plus
vite